the caring people over at the un
security council have chaired an
online meeting with uk foreign secretary
dominic raab good afternoon asking for
ceasefires in conflict zones
so people can be vaccinated against the
coronavirus
saying wait for it the world has a moral
duty to act
yeah the uk foreign secretary
i thank the united kingdom for
organizing this meeting
and for reinforcing my call for a global
ceasefire
rob wants areas in somalia sudan and
yemen to drop
arms have a cup of tea while the doctors
swoop in
jab the locals and swoop back out again
because
global vaccination coverage is essential
to beating coronavirus
i'll tell you what dom it'll get the
world's transport moving again quicker
too
you can get back to sending all those
british-made bombs and missiles to saudi
arabia
and then they can drop them on yemen
knowing that all the people being killed
are covered free don't worry about food
and water
it's all about being coveted free
charities have welcomed the request for
a little bit concerned
without a massive increase in production
of the vaccine the poorest countries
engulfed in conflict risk not getting
any at all the uk has estimated that 160
million people were at risk
and increases the likelihood of
vaccine-resistant strains emerging
with rob saying we have a moral duty to
act and a strategic necessity to come
together to defeat this virus
so the uk says it wants everybody to
have access to vaccines
but charity oxfam says the uk is
blocking the supply chain
and not sharing the recipe for private
manufacturers
one absolute pickle pandemic foreign
policy
pretending to vaccinate people before
sending more bombs